they are here every day from dawn until
dark dodging bulldozers and tipper
trucks for this
what these local villagers want is coal
and they'll trespass onto government
mines to get it
it's terrifying to watch as even very
young children race towards lorries
unloading piles of mine pit debris
sifting through the remains
to steal whatever little chunks of coal
they can find
that's 50 pence for this enormous risk
but people do it because they're
desperate
and we spot even more people on their
way
[Music]
this is happening in the plain view of
all the people who are officially
working here you know they can see what
is happening and it happens every single
day and although police we are told come
and periodically chase people off
tacitly they accept it because they know
if people aren't allowed to do this
however dangerous it might be they've
got nothing left
despite india's new 2017 net zero date
there's no clear targets for coal
and workers at this mine tell us they've
been told to extract more
because although india has ambitious
plans for renewable energy
lifting millions out of poverty means
power now and lots of it
when the world are saying we've got to
stop burning things we've got to stop
using coal is there a way we can do that
and balance that without sacrificing
these communities
do mining or don't do it mining but they
will do their mining by their own so
without coal
the entire area cannot exist
and as toxic as this air is the
villagers living next to these mines
don't want to move
the coal dust is filthy
clings to their lungs but this is
everything to them
[Music]
here
[Music]
is in
sight but here it will place a huge
demand on people
who care more about their family's
short-term survival than the global
climate crisis
[Applause]